laurent fabius est l'invité de preuves
par 3 bonsoir monsieur le premier
ministre ahmed est avec vous merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation voit
aussi bien sûr fait campagne dans cet
entre deux tours d'une primaire qui
pourrait d'ailleurs su révéler
périlleuse pour le parti socialiste en
quête de leadership depuis des années
oui si le score était trop serré je ne
sais pas si vous avez un pronostic
écoutez moi j'ai un souhait c'est que
martine aubry soit désigné soit
président de la république mais il
semble que ce soit probablement très
très serré très serré
de toutes les manières quel que soit le
titulaire de la victoire il y aura un
rassemblement et un univers à des
personnes comme moi y veilleront alors
tous les cas vous l'avez rappelé vous
êtes soutien de martine aubry dans cette
compétition la plus compatible à vos
yeux avec les idées sinon avec la
personne d'arnaud montebourg vous serez
interrogé dans un instant par christine
pouget de l' agence france-presse notre
partenaire et puis par perrine tarneaud
de public sénat nicolas sarkozy critique
la primaire socialiste il la juge
contraire à l'esprit de la vème
république et qui ne peut être l'otage
dit il dd parti est-ce qu'il a raison
sur le fond non je vais vous donner
l'explication parce que vous êtes
certainement haletant pourquoi est-ce
que ce sarkozy prend cette position qui
est d'ailleurs contredite par son
premier ministre monsieur fillon qui a
trouvé que les primaires étaient
d'excellente par le président de
l'assemblée nationale qui est du même
parti monsieur accoyer
alors pourquoi pourquoi monsieur sarkozy
prend t-il cette position et bien je
vais vous faire cette révélation c'est
parce que s'il y avait des primaires au
sein de l'ump il ne serait pas désigné
pour être candidat et voilà pourquoi il
prend cette position bien mais c'est
vrai qu'a priori on ne peut pas imaginer
des primaires dans un parti dont est
issu le président sortant cela vous le
reconnaissez on
cela ne concerne pas directement oui
mais enfin la réalité si vous voulez
c'est que compte tenu de la politique
qu'il mène
monsieur sarkozy est devenu très
impopulaire et qu'au delà de cette
impopularité la majorité des français y
compris à droite ne souhaitent pas qu'il
se représente et donc ils essayent de
noyer le poisson si on peut dire et puis
la réalité aussi c'est que les primaires
peut-être on va en parler on était
jusqu'ici être un très grand succès et
que la droite au lieu de reconnaître ce
succès est bon
simplement en disant c'est une bonne
idée on faire la même chose
essaye de s'accrocher aux branches on
avait déjà eu je ne sais pas si c'est
monsieur copé monsieur guéant d'autres
ou de tous les deux qui nous avait
expliqué que c'était attentatoires à la
démocratie qui alors des fiches à luxey
dans tout ça n'avait aucun sens et
l'autre jour je m'exprimais à la
télévision avec monsieur copé en face de
moi et je les remercier parce que je lui
ai dit j attendais pas que il avait
contribué à succès en critiquant de
manière tellement de l'absurde ce
système que finalement les gens avaient
été intéressés
non c'est un grand succès c'est une
démocratisation de la démocratie ça va
changer beaucoup de choses et je crois
que c'était le moment de le faire et il
faut reconnaître aussi tiers dans mon
mort d'homme ou de bord et est un des
promoteurs de cette affaire et martin
weale a décidé la organisé et c'est un
succès très bien le mérite leur revient
à tous les deux frangines aubry beaucoup
question ces nouveaux couples ont créé
cette émission évidemment laurent fabius
vous avez cité effectivement cette forme
de cacophonie dans la majorité vous avez
cité bernard accoyer également françois
fillon qui jugent effectivement que les
primaires sont un processus moderne est
ce qu'il ya une nouvelle ligne de
fracture dans la majorité le président
va pas loin déplacer pour
en juger mais je crois que moi j'ai vu
ça puisque j'étais à la semaine
nationale cet après midi on discute avec
des collègues de droite et beaucoup
d'entre eux disent que tôt ou tard ils
sont amenés à y venir
donc pour vous en tous les cas sur les
primaires de l'analyse de françois
fillon est la bonne celle là même que la
vôtre est ce que le premier ministre dit
vrai quand il dit qu actuellement sous
le poids des 17% d'arnaud montebourg au
premier tour il ya une surenchère à
gauche
il est très très aimable de s'intéresser
à nous ça doit lui faire la dérivatif
pour ses propres problèmes mais à des
plantations d'arbres qui sont fiers de
la france
oui enfin il ya ceux de la france qui
sont très lourds à en parler et puis il
ya ceux de son propre camp non je crois
que le problème ne se pose pas en termes
de surenchère le résultat des primaires
il faut le rappeler
bon françois hollande est arrivé en tête
moins que ce qu'il espérait qu'on fait
en tête martine aubry a fait un
excellent score
arnaud montebourg a été une surprise
puisqu'on pensait qu'il serait à jeu
avec ségolène royal et puis il a fait
nettement plus et alors du coup arnaud
c'est valoir je crois qu'il doit envoyer
une lettre ses propositions mme harel
sont connus et en ce qui concerne
martine aubry
le fait que c'est que les électeurs
d'arnaud montebourg se retrouve dans la
ligne de martins nourry ne pose pas de
problème elle n'a pas changé de ligne
puisque sur quelques points auxquels
tient au montebourg c'est à dire le fait
que l'europe doit être à la fois
offensive et défensive
le fait que les banques doivent être
beaucoup mieux contrôler le fait qu' il
faut moderniser notre système
institutionnel le fait qu'ils vont
lutter contre toutes les formes de
corruption
ce sont des thèmes dans laquelle non
seulement nous ne reconnaissons mais que
nous avons mis en avant donc ça ne pose
pas de problème on va en parler plus
longuement dans un instant mais quand
nicolas sarkozy aujourd'hui en
déplacement dans la creuse tient un
véritable discours de candidat un et
dénonce un déchaînement de démagogie
venant de la gauche aujourd'hui sur les
noirs il met notamment en avant le thème
de la démondialisation chère à arnaud
montebourg il met en avant les critiques
contre la casse des services publics
aussi en milieu rural et il voit là
c'est finalement ils dénoncent un
déchaînement de démagogie mais ça je ne
pense que ça marchera pas parce que le
moche telles qu'elles se présentent dans
cette élection est et sera sérieuse bon
moi je prends mon propre cas si on
voulait me faire passer pour quelque
agde incapable de gérer le pays
c'est raté donc il faut trouver un
équilibre il faudrait à la fois de très
sérieux notamment sur les finances
publiques les déficits qui sont énormes
et en même temps redonner un dynamisme
mais l'argument de démagogie
ça ne fonctionnera pas dans le problème
de ceux ci reconnaissent et que moi
j'étais en campagne depuis longtemps
d'ailleurs une personne mais sa
difficulté c'est quoi c'est que comme la
situation est mauvaise et qu'il est
président de la république est cuit ya
un rapport entre les deux même si la
crise explique pour une part les choses
ou bien il ne propose rien de nouveau et
dans ce cas là monsieur comme vous avez
obtenu mauvais résultat ce sera un vous
représentiez ou bien ils proposent des
choses même peut-être le fera t-il mais
sûrement il y met quand même pourquoi ne
l'avez vous pas fait et il aura beaucoup
de mal à sortir de ça alors vous dites
que le score sera certainement serré
dimanche au risque
la primaire bien sûr dimanche soir
goûter je ne sais pas qu'elle boostera
mais reconnaîtra le résultat d'ailleurs
dès dimanche soir parce qu'on voit que
c'est très difficile de compter les
bulletins il c'est difficile parce que
c'est ce sont les militants socialistes
eux mêmes qui ont organisé tout cela
vous l'avez vu il y avait une atmosphère
qui était très particulière dans les
bureaux de vote pas si vous avez
l'occasion de
du passé il y avait à la fois beaucoup
de solennité c'est un vrai vote et en
même temps une joie une convivialité
s'est très c'est très particulier
et là il faut du temps pour faire
remonter les bulletins il faut en même
temps isolés les listes électorales et
faire contrôler par huissier enfin on a
pris vraiment beaucoup de précautions je
crois qu'il ya une panne de telle ou
telle machine mais je pense que pour le
deuxième tour nous n'aurons pas ces
problèmes en tout cas j'espère en tout
cas martine aubry très vite a dit
qu'elle avait beaucoup de points de
convergence avec arnaud montebourg mais
ce dernier n'a cessé de répéter pendant
toute sa campagne puis finalement il y
avait une grande proximité entre martine
aubry et françois hollande lui ne fait
pas véritablement la différence c'est ce
que j'ai lu avec alors c'est ce que j'ai
vu il y en a une pour vous qui porterait
plus penchés les électeurs d'arnaud
montebourg sur votre favorite à côté moi
je les connais tous évidemment très bien
depuis longtemps
bon je pense que beaucoup d'électeurs de
d'arnaud montebourg sont prononcés poule
pour lui parce qu'il avait le sentiment
qu'il avait une ligne
disons de gauche pour pour parler
simplement de protestation et de
changement fort par rapport à l'existant
bon c'était la ligne aussi de martyr il
peut y avoir des différences hop tel ou
tel point mais je trouve que ces
électeurs si qui sont parfaitement
libres d'ailleurs arnaud l'année
personne n'est propriétaire de ses voix
se retrouveront plus facilement de ce
côté là pour vous ce n'est pas rose
bonnet et bonnet rose aubry hollande il
ya vachement devenir un coup de dés
beaucoup heureusement de points communs
puisque mais quand même y en a des bons
gérance de comment dire de tempérament
d'expérience de caractère et une gauche
molle
du côté de françois hollande non je
dirais que c'est une situation qui est
bannie depuis françois que jeuland
comment dire il a une position de
centriste de gauche bon et martine aubry
a une position centrale à gauche sait
déjà qu'elle est par sa position capable
de rassembler les socialistes bien sûr
ce qu'il fait à la tête du parti
socialiste
les noms socialistes et communistes et
autres radicaux les écologistes et puis
après il faudra rassembler les français
alors quand c'est cet élément de
position centrale qui est important
quand on veut être candidate
alors donc le gecko deux arguments à
laurent fabius donc je vous écoute il
serait invraisemblable qu'arnaud
montebourg par exemple disent je vote
hollande
je n'en sais rien mais selon votre
analyse
ça vous paraît invraisemblable écoutez
je peux pas me prononcer à la place with
no good bourg qui était un homme
du talent qui fera ce qu'il n'entend pas
faire bon simplement je crois qu'il ya
une logique pour ses électeurs
alors venez de centre gauche pour
françois hollande mais je note quand
même que martine aubry l'administrent la
ville de lille avec des élus du modem
alors exactes qui ont pris parti pour
son projet d'accord donc bien tout le
monde fait des risettes évidemment
arnaud montebourg depuis dimanche soir
franchement de laurent fabius vous
refusez de voir cette forme quand même
de condescendance qui exprime vis-à-vis
de son parti il a dit j'ai sorti le ps
du formol
oui le format le sait ce liquide
écoutez c'est la mêlée des arts jacasser
comparaison mais bon pour la bombe ont
accusé hier pas de commentaire vous vous
préféré ignorer son pouvoir de nuisance
aujourd'hui c'est pas du tout en ces
termes devant très bonnes relations
personnelles et pas et pour reprendre
votre comparaison
oui il n'ya pas de cadavres dans le
placard d'accord est ce qu'il apporte
des idées nouvelles vraiment arnaud
montebourg il a de la fougue du talent
et il met l'accent sur les choses en les
faisant ressortir des éléments que nous
mêmes développons et parfois depuis
longtemps mais plus on attend rassembler
musset je prends un exemple de référence
ce qui s'est passé à quelques années
vous rappeler le traité constitutionnel
européen tout le débat qui avait eu lieu
bon voilà je vous fais un point commun
où est le seul d'ailleurs dans ce cas là
parmi les allées contre les autres
compétiteurs avaient tous voté oui là
vous aviez un point d'accord avec arnaud
montebourg oui mais martine aubry dont
nous parlions a réuni autour d'elle les
gens qui ont voté oui des gens qui ont
voté non et je me rappelle que les
tenants des thèmes que j'abordais
c'était que oui je suis fondamentalement
pro européen mais l'europe doit être à
la fois offensive et défensive et nous
proposons déjà à l'époque le modifier le
rôle de la banque centrale européenne
faire en sorte que
les chinois ne puisse pas faire tout ce
qu'ils voulaient sans que nous puissions
aussi intervenir chez eux le fait que
j'étais contre les délocalisations ce
sont des thèmes qu'on retrouve c'est
très bien alors avant d'accueillir
christian pouget de l' agence
france-presse
donc on va voir concrètement ce que
demandent aujourd'hui arnaud montebourg
aux deux finalistes les deux impétrants
un coq il dit en vrai c'est tout de
suite avec margot aubriot c'est une
lettre qui est désormais au centre de
toutes les attentions
une lettre adressée par arnaud
montebourg deux candidats avec une
question qui intégrera le mieux ces
quatre conditions le protectionnisme
européen l'a mis sous tutelle des
banques
l'avènement d'une vième république et la
lutte contre la corruption avec ses 17%
de voir arnaud montebourg le sait il est
désormais l' arbitre du second tour des
primaires martine aubry ou françois
hollande à la première il ne pardonne
pas l' affaire guérini le second avait
rejeté son concept de 6ème république
pour moi ce sont les deux faces d'une
même pièce
martine aubry françois hollande je les
dis dans la campagne sont les héritiers
d'une même tradition politique
ils ont le même projet d'ailleurs
martine aubry elle même a déclaré
qu'elle n'avait pas différence de
projets avec françois hollande
elle n'avait que des différences de
tempérament je ne crois pas qu'on
dérange les millions d'électeurs pour
des querelles de tempérament l'équation
est délicate mais arnaud montebourg fera
son choix
hier il avait entretenu le doute
aujourd'hui le député de saône et loire
l'a décidé je prendrai mes
responsabilités ça veut rien dire
ben si ça veut dire que je suis un
dirigeant politique je suis capable
moi-même de faire des choix et donc je
ferai certainement un choix
sa voix il la monnaie est maintenant au
prix fort il réclame aux candidats un
engagement écrit il publiera même leurs
réponses entre séduction et refus de se
laisser manipuler martine aubry et
françois hollande e n'accepteront pas
toutes ces exigences
suis pas non maintenant je suis françois
hollande ça vous a pas échappé
sinon vous auriez été victime d'une
illusion
je ne vais pas reprendre le projet d
autres temps c'est quand même un comble
celui qui a fait près de 40 % finissent
par reprendre le projet de ce qu'ils ont
fait beaucoup moins reste à savoir si
arnaud montebourg se prononcera à titre
personnel ou si il appellera ses
électeurs à le suivre
réponse dans la semaine après le débat
de l'entre-deux tours des primaires
socialistes voilà et donc christine
projet nous a rejoint de l'agent
strasbourg vous dites que vous avez très
bonnes relations avec un moment de vous
qui a pas de cadavre grand placard mais
enfin on a un peu l'impression que les
deux finalistes sont un peu les otages
d'arnaud montebourg qu'est ce que vous
en pensez
je ne crois pas je compare tout cas je
peux parler pour ce qui concerne la
percée dès que je soutiens qui est
partie des noms et les convergences ou
face il était naturel bon mais on a
beaucoup parlé de cela c'est vrai c'est
vrai autour d'eux oui mais comme non
plus non oui mais comme nous l'avons
souiller les uns les autres
bon on va faire un très bon score mais
en même temps il reconnaît lui-même que
les électrices et électeurs feront ce qu
ce qu'il souhaite
de ce point de vue là je veux faire un
pronostic vous me disiez que votre
procès je pense qu'il y aura au deuxième
tour pas mal de gens qui n'étaient pas
allés voter au premier tour est aussi
fortement peut-être des gens qui étaient
allés aux producteurs qui n'ont pas de
dieu et notamment des personnes qui ne
sont pas socialistes et qui d'habitude
ne vote pas socialiste mais qui vote à
gauche bon parce que ces personnes là se
rencontrent se rendre compte de plus en
plus que pour la première fois ils ont
la possibilité de l ont la possibilité
ces personnes de choisir pour qui elles
vont voter au deuxième tour
d'habitude admettez vous êtes
écologistes vous êtes front de gauche où
vous êtes bon en tout cas mme n'est pas
socialiste vous votez pas associer ce
premier tour mais au deuxième tour comme
the cell est en tête
vous devez voter pour lui ou pour elle
mais vous n'avez pas choisi cette fois
ci ces personnes qui peuvent être des
centaines de milliers vont dire voilà
pour qui au deuxième tour je vais voter
et je pense que on ne s'est pas encore
rendu compte de cela et ça peut faire
appel non mais c'est le sens parce qu'on
est en finale
si vous voulez la personnalité qui sera
désigné sera vraisemblablement opposé à
nicolas sarkozy est vraisembablement
présidente de la république
donc on peut choisir qui sait mais vous
pensez par exemple que les électeurs de
ségolène royal pourrait venir au
deuxième tour voter malgré tout vous
pensez qu'il s'est pas trop attachés à
la personne de ségolène royal sera sa
personne mais il ya aussi un projet
politique de ce point de vue là si je
peux me permettre j'ai trouvé que le
façon dont ce royal a été traité y
compris d'ailleurs pas certain nombre de
responsables socialistes n'étaient pas
cohérents c'est bien elle fait une
campagne que j'ai trouvé très courageuse
et et de qualité et puis pour
différentes raisons n'a pas obtenu le
résultat que d'ailleurs les sondages lui
prédisaient les sondages se sont trompés
un voile et moi j'ai mon pronostic c'est
que c'est au nom royal rebondir on est
donc en plus
une femme en difficulté c'est pas le
enfin que ce soit de l'élégance de la
courtoisie ou de là il faut pas il faut
pas traiter des gens comme ça et donc
moi je trouve que elle rebondira ou
est-ce que vous la voyez demain quel
rôle peut être joué elle jouera un rôle
dans la république assurément vous
l'avais appelé voulaient manifester un
soutien oui je lui dis un certain nombre
de choses d'une manière directe ou
indirecte et je vous dis ce que je pense
alors il ya un sondage qui vient de
tomber opinionway et qui donne 54 % pour
hollande et 46 pour aubry chez les
sympathisants de gauche
est ce que ça vous inquiète c'est le jeu
précédent de da combien il était un peu
moins favorable de françois hollande
oui il donnait quatre points de plus
dans un cas comme dans l'autre
je ne sais pas quels sont les résultats
il faut être très prudent parce que
personne ne les connaît et dont il
refaire son retard oui oui maintenant je
pense que c'est par l'intoxication ce
que je vous dis pas ce que j'essaye
d'avoir un sentiment une intuition marc
théorie et comme on dit dans d'autres
cercles sur la montante
vous voulez dire que les combatifs lé
week end les dents dans l habite la
fonction le bit le rôle sans être
arrogant parce que sans être
présomptueux personne n'habitait pas
vain je trouve que plus la campagne se
déroule plus
quand on la voit quand on l'entend on se
dit elle ferait une excellente
présidente madame de la république et
vous aussi michel conscient que ça
concerne aussi les hommes curieux ce
sera le président de tous les français
le ton sexe quand vous avez analysé les
résultats de la primaire du premier tour
qu'elle est la géographie électorale que
vous pouvez en tirer est ce que c'est
bien vrai que c'est hollande qui est
plutôt l'homme les gérera j'étais enfin
gardé sa suffisamment précis débarque
donc je voudrais pas me dire de sottises
je peux vous dire
deux constats alors évident que j'ai
fait d'abord chez moi en normandie
je connais très bien on ne peut pas
faire un découpage rural urbain
si on faisait ce découpage là on se
tromperait en revanche par exemple à
paris c'est vrai que martine aubry a
fait un excellent score et france
hollande moins bon mais à lyon aussi
de g comme vous le savez une maison dans
l'ariège je prenais donc connaissance
des résultats dans l'ariège françois
hollande est arrivé en tête mais là où
martine aubry était soutenu
vigoureusement par des élus elle est
arrivée en traîneau savez il ya
tellement d'éléments qui peuvent jouer
qui ont pu jouer je ne ferai pas de jeu
je ne suis pas capable de faire une
analyse d'ensemble asus on a
l'impression quand même que au fil des
dés de l'aide de la semaine c'est-à-dire
le ton se durcit beaucoup entre les deux
finalistes
ça reste quand même très policé écoutez
un peu lisses et peau lissée hollande
qui juge que même que les critiques de
madame aubry à son égard sont insidieuse
passage aux briques
voilà exactement et fait parler de lui
mais vous savez s'il d'abord il faut
toujours rester très mesuré
c'est ma nature en observant et ses
besoins des personnes très responsable
mais je crois que les choses resteront
très mesuré en même temps il faut
débattre alors c'est toute la difficulté
du débat qui a lieu
je dis c'est que il faut à la fois
discuté sans se disputait donc son
sachet
je n'ai pas d'inquiétude et je n'ai pas
d'inquiétude pour l'issue et quelle que
soit la personne qui l'emportera il y
aura rassemblement et c'est là où des
personnes comme moi pourrons jouer un
rôle si c'était nécessaire mais je le
crois pas c'est à dire je pense que ça
se passera très bien spontanément mais
quel rôle vous pourriez s'il y a si
jamais il y avait des excès on pourrait
être pour être amené à ce moment-là
rappeler les uns et les autres à la
mesure mais je sais pas ce que ce soit
pas nécessaire vous pensez vraiment oui
oui oui
et même si le score est serré ne pensez
pas qu'il pourrait y avoir quand même
une crainte sur le parti convives un peu
un congrès de reims bis si le score est
très serré
non je ne crois pas penser que la partie
ne sera pas diviser en deux noms et de
toutes les manières si vous voulez si on
veut les socialistes et beaucoup de
français rejet a longtemps eu x change
donc ils ont envie que la persuade des
socialistes gagnent et on sait que
l'unité tab sont indispensables donc
voilà il faut que les conditions de
l'unité soit respectée non je n'ai pas
d'inquiétude si par malheur pour vous
françois hollande passé en tête vous
avez eu des mots quand même assez peu
amènes pour françois hollande
on se souvient dans votre petite phrase
à bordeaux quand elle a été rapporté
mais ce n'est pas je ne vais pas
prononcé de république de ses phrases
qui de ses phrases que ce n'est pas mon
style habituel vous le savez bien donc
voilà bon je connais très bien françois
hollande je connais très bien martine
aubry je connais très bien ségolène
royal depuis des années avec lui on le
sait bien 5
dire ça c'est leur valise et vos
rapports avec hollande écouter un son
différent gemmayzé des bandes jugement
puisque je connais bien les uns et les
autres et j'ai formé mon jugement et ce
jugement m'a conduit à soutenir très
fortement martine aubry alors il ya des
divergences de fond aujourd'hui
concernant les le programme notamment et
les propositions mises en avant par
françois hollande je pense notamment au
recrutement à nouveau de 60 mille
professeurs dans l'éducation nationale
il a chiffré cela lors du débat du
dernier débat deux milliards et demi
d'euros et en expliquant passer le coût
du redoublement est ce que vous avez été
satisfait par les explications de
françois hollande
alors dites-nous franchement vous savez
en plus on m'a confié la tâche et que je
remplirai je rendrai public pas public
alors que je donnerais à la personnalité
qui aura été désigné au début novembre
je regarde là quand même vomir année la
publication du projet mais cette mesure
n est pas dans le projet il ya l'aspect
financier mais pas seulement financier
bon là dessus par tiendrait une bonne
formule que je reprends volontiers à mon
compte et après je vous parlerai
finances il ne peut pas y avoir dans
bausch sans réforme et il ne peut pas y
avoir de réforme sans embauche bon terre
qu'il faut prendre l'ensemble du champ
on a besoin de moyens dans l'éducation
nationale parce que les coupes sont ou
ont été tellement fortes que il faut
bien sûr des moyens
en même temps ces moyens doivent être
assorties d'une discussion avec les
organisations syndicales qui le
souhaitent qu'ils demandent
sur le fond alors le fond c'est la
polémologie le fond c'est l'organisation
du travail
le fond c
le salaire des enseignants le fond c'est
la présence enfin beaucoup beaucoup de
choses donc il y aura certainement des
embauches mais je crois qu'il faut
prendre l'ensemble du problème
d'insalubrité à la maintenance sur
l'aspect proprement financiers moi vous
savez j'étais une du budget puis
ministre des finances je connais un
petit peu cela quand on doit regarder
l'aspect financier il faut regarder pas
simplement le cou à la dernière année
mais le coût additionnel
bon alors si on part de l'idée que ces
douze mille fonctionnaires par an et que
ce type de fonctionnaires une fois
chargé coûte quelque chose comme 50
mille euros par an vous pouvez faire le
calcul quand vous additionnez pendant
cinq ans ça vous fait beaucoup de
milliards mais qu'est ce que les deux
milliards et demi annoncé françois faire
le calcul
mais faisons attention remarque plus à
l'est puis ce sera le moment en
indication n'auront pas beaucoup de
marge de manoeuvre parce que les
déficits que nous laissons colossaux la
croissance malheureusement risque d'être
faible
donc il faudra avoir des priorités
bon parmi ses priorités il ya évidemment
l'éducation que près été très très forte
mais il faudra
donc toujours avoir à l'esprit que il ya
des embauches à faire je le répète mais
qu'il ya des changements qualitatifs à
opérer et qu'il faudra associer les
partenaires sociaux pour là donc ça
c'est vrai pour l'éducation nationale
mais ces francofolies sécurité c'est
vrai dans le domaine de l'emploi c'est
vrai dans beaucoup de domaines pour tous
les salariés qui approchent de l'âge de
la retraite aussi à ça c'était de notre
sujet oui ça c'est un autre sujet on est
face au déficit là aussi oui oui bien
sûr les déficits là nous avons pris des
engagements et nous nous avons chiffré
est dans les chiffres que moi-même
j'intègre j'ai intégré l'engagement
collectif que nous avons pris en ce qui
concerne la retraite et dans ce que
disait montbourg la caisse qu'il ya
quelque chose qui vous paraît très
négociable ou pas négociable à savoir la
tutelle des banques
qu'est ce que ce sera chaud les banques
est ce que vous en pensiez la chaux les
banques
ce que dit à la fois arnaud montebourg
et ségolène royal parce que c'est un
thème qu'elle a beaucoup augmenté nous
paraît intéressant il ya quatre ou cinq
thèmes sur lesquels moi je me retrouve
totalement
premièrement il nous paraît absolument
nécessaire que il y est un contrôle plus
plus plus sérieux des activités
bancaires et donc
là ça passe à la fois par une séparation
entre les banques de dépôt et les
banques d'affaires
parce que le mélange finalement est très
critiquable et ça passe dans certains
cas par le fait qu'il doit y avoir des
représentants de l'état au conseil
d'administration pour empêcher toute une
série c'est un premier point un deuxième
point c'est que par exemple je ne trouve
pas normal que les banques puissent
avoir des filiales dans les paradis
fiscaux un troisième point c'est qu'il
faut créer une banque publique
d'investissement pour aider les pme
un quatrième point c'est qu'il faut
changer les relations entre les usagers
consommateurs et les banques le problème
des agios et un cinquième point c'est
qu'il faut qu'il y ait une taxe sur les
transactions financières sur tous ces
points nous sommes en accord à la fois
avec ségolène et avec un goal mais sur
la démondialisation
ça c'était notre thématique on peut
discuter sur le thème si vous voulez sur
le terme excusez moi sur le terre ce que
martine aubry avait été très seyant on
peut discuter sur le terme mais le fait
qu' il faut réguler la mondialisation et
que s'agissant de l'europe
il faut que l'europe je vous ai tout à
l'heure monsieur grossiord soit à la
fois offensive mais aussi défensive
ouverte mais pas offerte et la cohérence
et une trêve
ces deux formules et c'est exactement ça
et il faut qu'une vraie régulation de la
mondialisation ce qui n'est pas le cas
de georges un mot à propos de la banque
dexia vous avez mis
mis en doute il ya quelques jours le
sauvetage de cet établissement en disant
ah là là si l'état s'engage la france
pourrait mettre en péril son triple a
n'est pas ce qui se passe apparemment
pour l'instant laurent fabius et le
gouvernement veut aller vite dans le
sauvetage de cette banque des
collectivités locales en france
particulièrement
donc ça passe par son démantèlement et
laurent feuz françois fillon met en
cause la gauche qui a aussi pesé dans
dans la gestion de cet établissement
autre chose dans sa vie en question
est-ce que vous voterez alors est-ce que
vous voterez ce sauvetage de vous dire
on va voir exactement quel texte
le moment n'a pas le texte mais c'est
vrai qu'à partir d'une banque qui était
consacré aux collectivités locales petit
à petit tel monsieur le troadec saisi
par la débauche cette banque a fait
énormément de choses et a été très
imprudent le regard qu'il a introduites
sont annoncés viennent en fait oui mais
les les imprudences ont été liés aux
dirigeants de l'époque par michel rocard
était le dirigeant d'abord ils étaient
partagés que je crois que il ya une
opération très imprudente qui ont été
faites bon en 2008 le gouvernement a
proposé un projet que nous n'avons pas
voté derrière l'assemblée disant voilà
la solution pour solde de tout compte
moyennant quoi
trois ans après ça revient de manière
très négative
bon il faut bien faire quelque chose
évidemment pour des classes que j'ai dit
je le maintiens non je n'ai pas dit du
tout que il y aurait une conséquence
automatique
j'ai dit faisons attention je dis
faisons attention parce que il faut bien
sûr agir
mais quand on agit en donnant des
garanties au bout du compte si les
garanties joue évidemment il n'y a pas
besoin d'être un grand spécialiste pour
comprendre que ça a un effet sur notre
caddie et les agences de notation on dit
je vais dans votre sens et pas tout à
fait il n'y a pas d'effet sur le
classement de la france actuellement oui
actuellement en tous les cas vous verrez
si vous montrez ce plan de sauvetage
dans quelques jours à l'assemblée
nationale merci papa sans condition ses
racines aux conditions ça va vous allez
regarder donc
merci à une fois de plus christine on va
voir maintenant avec tam traduit le sens
de votre engagement aujourd'hui laurent
fabius on va aborder à nouveau certaines
motivations sans doute en rapport avec
l'un des deux finalistes à on va voir ça
c'est que tout cela
laurent fabius l'a décidé la
présidentielle ce n'est plus pour lui il
faut dire que l'ex premier ministre a
bien trébuché lors de la primaire de
aujourd'hui il préfère rester en retrait
derrière martine aubry à qui il apporte
ses talents oratoires
laurent fabius est aussi un pugnace que
dans les campagnes électorales il sait
trouver les formules les angles qui font
mouche
mais la majorité n'est pas la seule à
faire l'objet des attaques de sa langue
acérée
il arrive aussi que leur en abuse s'en
prennent à certains camarades du parti
une de ses cibles préférées françois
hollande lui n'a jamais considéré
françois hollande comme quelqu'un qui a
des convictions vraiment accroché c'est
d'ailleurs le sens de toutes les petites
phrases quand il dit on n'a jamais vu un
éléphant caché derrière une fraise des
bois des ongs françois hollande est une
fraise des bois
françois hollande incarne la gauche
caoutchouc et à bordeaux laurent fabius
aurait déclaré françois hollande
président on rêve
derrière ces phrases moqueuse
existerait-il une rancune plus tenaces
pour celui que laurent fabius pen a
considéré comme son égal en 1984
françois hollande n'était que conseiller
occulte de l'elysée alors que laurent
fabius était déjà premier ministre
vingt ans plus tard en 2005 lors du
référendum sur la constitution
européenne
les escarmouches feutrée se sont
transformés en guerre ouverte
aujourd'hui du côté de martine aubry on
relativise ces attaques ad hominem
je pense pas que laurent fabius soit
quelqu'un qui regarde la politique par
le petit bout de la lorgnette à savoir
les petites phrases sur les uns aux
autres toujours est il que laurent
fabius aurait du mal à jouer son rôle de
sage actif auprès de françois hollande
si ce dernier l'emportait à la
présidentielle en revanche tout serait
différent si la maire de lille se
retrouvaient à l'elysée alors on
pourrait imaginer un retour en grâce
comme récemment alain juppé au fond
l'exemple de d'alain juppé c'est un peu
une petite lumière pour lui c'est un
puissant une puissante lumière qui lui
permet de se dire un retour est possible
voilà perrine tarneaud est avec nous
pour ce dernier quart d'heure de
l'émission laurent fabius vous avez
raison de dire qu'il faut pas regarder
les choses par le petit peu calmé vous
avez déjà un petit peu rangé au placard
alors que c'est pas vrai la preuve la
multiplication de toutes vos
interventions médiatiques là depuis des
jours les baby que des monsieur mais
simplement pour pour à la fois plaisante
et être sérieux
j'ai décidé de ne pas être candidat à la
présidence de la république j'aurais
très bien pu être candidat reste
d'ailleurs beaucoup de ceux qui
aujourd'hui soutiennent tel ou tel des
finalistes le demander bon mais ça c'est
pour ma mémoire personnelle mais
simplement gelé décider parce que
j'estime être pas être en situation et
je m'en félicite parce que c'est là le
petit trait d'humour depuis que j'ai
décidé de ne pas être candidat à la
présidence de la république tous les
dirigeants socialistes m'adore donc je
suis très très content non c'est bon
pour les bourgmestres non seulement à
cette ambition mais gégé
c'est le hasard ddd chaude et exercé
toutes les fonctions d'appui sofcap
sénateurs ils sont présents à un public
oui oui mais ça pour cette fois ci ça me
paraît compromis alors il va falloir que
je rattrape une ambition dans ce marché
est donc clairement je veux que la
gauche gagne je te jure je pense qu'il
faut changer profondément les choses
dans ce pays et donc j'aiderai la
personne qui gagnera et à ce stade j'ai
dis parce que connaissant les uns les
autres jugeant la difficulté des
situations le caractère la force les
convictions les projets que mon soutien
à l'euro mais de toutes les manières je
serai quelqu'un de parfaitement loyal
les questions européennes et surtout
internationale était très très peu
présente dans les débats du premier tour
de la primaire prend quelque chose que
vous avez regretté
oui
d'une certaine façon mais c'est un peu
un grand classique vous savez dans les
débats on l'aimé toujours en troisième
ou quatrième partie et puis alors comme
ça déborde temps alors j'ai entre deux
tours est ce que demain ces questions
intéressent elles sont prévues elles
sont prévues j'espère qu'elles seront
traités parce que d'une façon générale
elles sont déterminantes et surtout
cette fois ci puisque on est évidemment
très largement déterminée par ce qui se
passe en europe et on a beaucoup de
choses à dire sur l'international sur la
question palestinienne sur l'afrique
noire sur la question américaine que que
j'aime beaucoup et en plus je suis
quelqu'un qui voyage qui donne des cours
dans des universités internationales sur
les questions que je suis mais je vous
vois venir
vous aimeriez incarner ces questions
internationales dans un futur
gouvernement ne lui je n'ouvre pas du
tout
mais au moment où on a sonné d'ailleurs
un très bon ministre
parce que à chaque fois que lui ou moi
ce matériau dit mais pourquoi est ce
qu'il n'ya pas une présidence 20 duels
entre super fabricants et nous faisons
tous les deux la même réponse
le
nous estimons à l'autre mais la calvitie
n'est pas un élément suffisant de
classification politique alors qu'ici on
a vu dans le petit sujet à l'instant que
carlo mais fait une analogie finalement
entre vos parcours à votre votre
parcours et celui d'alain juppé vous
reconnaissez vous aussi des similitudes
la jupe est beaucoup plus âgée que moi
et puis très exactement
oui oui bah écoutez c'est vrai que on a
eu le le vraiment le les normes des
avantages de faire les bonnes études et
avantages est premier ministre
à cg oui oui oui mais enfin c'est quand
même un grand honneur une grande chance
et après nos parcours était différent
nos choix sont différents mais il
n'empêche que je c'est quelqu'un que
j'estime nickel je vis tous les deux
adoubé par de trois personnalités
monétique très lourd très lourd très
lourd à porter
brillant d'entre nous vas-y et jacques
chirac l'emporté parce que salée j'avais
lu à une analyse philosophe assez
intéressante sur qu'est ce que c'est
qu'un dauphin et ce philosophe qui
termine un historien disait le delfina
puisque c'est le nom ça ne marche jamais
parce que regarder son dauphin s'est
regardé sa propre mort pas mal mais quel
regard vous portez aujourd'hui sur la
résurrection politique et médiatique
d'un jeu réchauffe je suis laïc
non mais sur le parcours actuel d'alain
juppé beauté mais aussi arnaud serait
pas simplement je trouve cependant un
peu de distance que
depuis qu'il a pris ses fonctions la
politique étrangère de la france est
mieux tenus il avait sa tentation de
venise un moment alain juppé et vous oui
mais il ya longtemps je crois a fait il
a eu des épreuves et ses bois non
moelleux
le jour où je déciderai d'aller à venise
irait la politique étrangère est mieux
tenues vous pourriez rendre hommage
également à nicolas sarkozy oui mais
était assez explicite un agent de la
paix aujourd'hui on l'a vu en libye il
ya dans autant en matière économique et
sociale je suis très critique sur ce
qu'a fait monsieur sarkozy en politique
étrangère il faut faire deux colonnes
bon il ya du positif et du négatif sur
le négative on sait le discours de dakar
sur l'homme africain qui est entré dans
l'histoire leleu mauvaise analyse et
comportements sur la tunisie enfin toute
une série de shows de lait des zigzags
sur la chine dont il faut voter positif
que vous avez le comportement nouveau
été positif en libye bon nouveau parce
qu'on a quand même reçu avant monsieur
kadhafi une une certaine énergie montré
dans beaucoup de domaines simplement
l'histoire faire la diplomatie il faut
avoir une vision longue et ce qui me
frappe c'est que monsieur sarkozy a
souvent une attitude qui sont plutôt des
coups il fait des coups mais en
diplomatie c'est très dangereux parce
que vous retrouvez les mêmes partenaires
et donc si vous faites un coup une fois
en prenant de billets un partenaire
après ça on vous le renvoi négativement
donc il manquait peut-être au début
après l'expérience des espèces de vision
historique et ça alors monsieur sarkozy
a de l'énergie
mais souvent on se dit mais est ce que
cette énergie est bien employé et
souvent nous répondons aujourd'hui
laurent fabius un accord a été trouvé
entre matignon et les députés de la
majorité sur la taxe sur les hauts
revenus qui s'appliquera à partir de 250
mille euros à ce que la charge de la
dette
nous sommes ainsi plus équitablement
répartis c'était une petite contribution
mais je crois que le chiffre que j'ai vu
c'est qu'on va demander aux français les
plus modestes 1 milliards et quelques au
titre de la taxe sur les mutuelles de
santé et on va demander aux français les
plus fortunés de 100 millions ce sera ce
un peu plus d'un an maintenant
oui on aura deux on aura redonné 1
milliard 800 millions avec les
modifications d'impôt sur la fortune
donc il ya un milliard 400 millions de
différence au détriment du budget de
l'état ça vous espérer que le sénat de
gauche sert de vitrine bien au parti
socialiste aujourd'hui notamment en
matière budgétaire
il y aura bien sûr une position
importante du sénat de majorités de
gauche le pour le budget mais l'un des
points ce qu'elle je souhaiterais très
modestement que le sénat et par tuer la
majorité c'est un travail c'est la
préparation du projet de
décentralisation
parce que ça fait partie de nos
propositions c'est très important
le sénat et la chambre des collectivités
locales je pense que nos amis sénateurs
sont magnifiquement placé pour préparer
vraiment ce que doit être un nouvel acte
de décentralisation et moi je serai
d'autant plus sensible que comme je vous
le disais je le travaille sur les
projets de loi que nous devrons
présenter déjà annoncé sa volonté partie
qu'on reçoit voilà les centrales et moi
je cours je compte beaucoup sur le sénat
pour préparer l'assemblée nationale il
peut pas faire grand-chose jean pierre
vernant mais bien sûr on va faire passer
les projets mais les préparer c'est très
important quand on arrive dans un
nouveau cycle politique que les projets
soient prêts par des gens qui s'y
connaissent ce qui est le cas du sénat
j'ai une dernière question qui n'a rien
à voir avec tout ça laurent fabius
l'elysée se prépare un heureux événement
est ce qu'il sera strictement privé ça
je ne sais pas tout ce que je peux dire
mais j'ai déjà laissé entendre de
l'autre jour
mon collègue c'est que si cet événement
a lieu comme cela semble être le cas je
souhaite avoir beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de bonheur à la famille et un
très long congé de paternité à monsieur
ça c'est qu'elle souhaitait pas vraiment
prendre de coups j'ai différé
l'essentiel c'est qu'il soit là enfin
plus de variété avec nous aujourd'hui
c'est la fin de ce prof par trois bons
sera tous à la semaine prochaine